-Welcome back.
We are hanging out
with Vince Vaughn!
Come on, now.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-I had this idea
for this game for you
'cause you've been
in so many great movies.
Alright?
And I wanted to see that
if you're a big enough fan
of movies
that you can summarize a movie
in just five seconds.
It's time for
"Five Second Summaries."
Here we go.
-♪ One, two, three,
four, five seconds ♪
♪ Summaries ♪
-Now, here's how the game works.
We'll be given
the name of a movie.
It'll pop up
on your Zoom screen.
And as soon as you see
the title in your prompter,
you will have five seconds
to describe the plot
the best way you can and try
to make me guess what it is.
You can't use any words
in the title,
actors' names, or catch phrases.
You're just describing
the plot of the movie.
Does that sound good?
-Okay. Yeah, yeah.
Let's give it a shot.
-Alright.
You're my guest, Vince,
so, please, you're up first.
Let's put five seconds
on the clock.
Take a look at the movie
in your prompter.
And whenever you're ready.
-Okay. Go.
Haunted hotel. Family. Dad chops
down a door with an axe.
-"Amityville Horror"?
No. Oh, no.
The one with Jack Nicholson.
[ Buzzer ]
"The Shining." "The Shining."
[ Bell dings ]
-That's right. That's right.
-I'm allowed to beat --
I'm allowed to answer
longer than five seconds.
-That was a broad --
That was a broad description.
It could have been either one.
It was just a --
-Alright. Here we go.
Can I have five seconds
on the clock?
Oh, okay. Yep.
Okay. Ready? Go.
-Mm-hmm.
-There's a guy
living in his basement.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
-A guy living in his basement.
[ Laughter ]
I have no answer for this.
-That's not true. You have to
have an answer for it.
There's a guy living
in his basement.
-There's a guy,
and he's living in his basement.
That's where he lives.
[ Laughter ]
That happened to be
a home for him.
This is an under
five-second description
of a movie that one might know.
-Yeah, that is correct.
-And that description
is that there's a gentleman
living in his basement.
That's the best description.
That's the premise
that we're working with.
We have five seconds
to answer this question.
I hope that that's clear to you.
I will say, um, although
he wasn't living in a basement,
but he was sort of isolated.
I'll say "Being There,"
for the buzz.
[ Buzzer ]
-Mm, sorry.
-Yeah, that's wrong.
-"Parasite."
-"Parasite"!
I sadly never saw "Parasite."
[ Laughter ]
-Well, alright, there you go.
-But you know what? I bet
it's a terrific description,
and I'm going to take the full
blame
for "Parasite"
not being answered.
-No, no, no, I think --
-Well, no, I am, because if
I would have seen "Parasite" --
-I just ruined the movie
for you, I think.
-It was impossible
for me to get that correct,
and you deserved better, Jimmy.
I feel like little Poco Bueno.
-See, that's unbelievable.
See, that's unbelievable.
That's the kind of --
He gives, and he gives,
and he gives.
-Guess what?
Sometimes you start slow,
but it's not over.
Tomorrow's a new day.
Let's go. Three seconds.
Here we go.
-We're making it
a little tighter.
Three seconds on the clock.
Vince Vaughn is up.
Vince, whenever you're ready,
say "Go."
-Go. Giant ape royalty
fights giant lizard.
-"Godzilla vs. Kong."
[ Buzzer ]
[ Bell dings ]
Wow! That was so fast!
-That was right.
This is the comeback.
This is how we spell redemption.
-Alright. Here we go. I got
three seconds for this one?
Oh, no, no.
-Hopefully I've seen it.
-Yeah, I know. I don't know.
Alright, ready? Here we go.
-Here we go.
-Go.
White fisherman's sweater.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Fisherman's sweater?
-[ Laughs ]
Yes.
-It's a sweater of a fisherman,
and the color of this sweater
happens to be white.
-Yep. Kind of stole the movie
a little bit.
-I think once again, you've
given a terrific, terrific,
terrific --
[ Laughter ]
-You think so?
-Terrific --
I think you given
a terrific thing,
but I'm afraid
I may not have seen this movie.
I might have been in my library
reading Ben Franklin's
biography.
-Oh, my God.
[ Southern accent ] What if I
said it with this accent?
Uh...
-Well, then I would think
that it's probably
the best clue ever given
if someone had seen the movie
once again.
And this is now
an uncomfortable moment.
-[ Normal voice ] It was --
Chris Evans was wearing
the sweater,
and the movie was "Knives Out."
-"Knives Out." And that is
probably a fantastic movie --
and Chris Evans no doubtedly --
and no doubtedly, Chris Evans
dazzled in that movie.
-Final round, we're going
to put one second
on the clock.
-Final round.
-One second.
You have to summarize the movie
in one second.
Whenever you're ready.
-Go. Dating, wine, California.
[ Buzzer ]
-Dating, wine, California.
Dating, wine, California.
Alright, so,
if I was dating somebody --
It's like Sonoma --
-You're putting yourself
in the moment.
I like this.
-Yeah.
Oh, is it "Eat Pray Love?"
No -- Dating. Nope.
That wasn't California.
That was Italy.
Dating, wine --
Is it the one
with Paul Giamatti?
-Yeah!
-That's correct.
-That's correct?
[ Bell dings ]
-That is correct.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Sideways."
-"Sideways"!
-"Sideways."
-Yes!
-Have you seen "Sideways"?
-Yes, I did.
I saw "Sideways." Yes.
We have one more shot at --
-We have one more shot
at being who we are,
which is a terrific tandem.
Let's give it a go.
-One second on the clock.
We got this. I know we have it.
-That's all we need!
-Ready for this?
-Yes!
-Go. Mouse chef.
[ Buzzer ]
-Mouse chef is a little film
that went by the name
of "Ratatouille."
-Yes! That's what
I'm talking about.
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
My thanks to Vince Vaughn.
Stick around. We'll be right
back with more "Tonight Show,"
everybody. Come on.
♪♪